so that might change completely
like everything that's said converted to
text might change
completely the dynamics of what we do in
this world especially now with remote
work right exactly
exactly it was with zoom and so on
that's that's fascinating to think about
i mean for me i care about podcasts
right and one of the things that was
you know i'm torn i know a lot of the
engineers at spotify
so i i love them very much because
they uh they dream big in terms of like
they want to empower creators so one of
my hopes was with spotify that they
would use a technology like rev or
something like that to
to start converting everything
into uh into text and make it indexable
like one of the things that
that sucks with podcasts is like it's
hard to find stuff
like the the model is basically
subscription like
you find uh it's similar use
it's similar to what youtube used to be
like which is you basically find a
creator that you
enjoy and you subscribe to them and like
you just
yeah you just kind of follow what
they're doing but the search and
discovery
wasn't a big part of youtube like in the
early days
but and that's what currently with
podcasts like is the search and
discovery is
uh like non-existent you're basically
searching for like the dumbest possible
thing which is like keywords
in the titles of episodes yeah even
aside from searching discover like all
the time so i listen to
like a number of podcasts and um you
know there's something said and i want
to like
go back to that later because i was
trying i'm trying to remember what do
you say like maybe like recommended some
cool product that i want to try out
and like it's basically impossible maybe
like some people have pretty good show
notes
so maybe you'll get lucky and you can
find it right but i mean if
everyone had transcripts and it was all
searchable it was a game-changer
it'd be so much better i mean that's one
of the things that
i i wanted to i mean one of the reasons
we're talking today
is i wanted to take this quite seriously
the the rough thing i just been lazy
so uh because i'm very fortunate that a
lot of people support this podcast that
there's enough money now to do
uh transcription so on it
it seemed clear to me especially like
ceos and
sort of uh like phds like people
write to me who are like graduate
students in computer science or graduate
students of whatever the heck field it's
clear that their mind
like they enjoy podcasts when they're
doing laundry or whatever
but they want to revisit the
conversation in a much more rigorous way
and they really want a transcript like
it's clear that they want to like
analyze
conversations like so many people wrote
to me about a transcript for
your shabbat conversation i had just a
bunch of
conversations and then on the elon musk
side like reporters
want like they want to write a blog post
about your conversation
so they want to be able to pull stuff
and it's like
they're essentially doing on your
conversation transcription
privately they're doing it for
themselves and then starting to pick
but so much easier when you can actually
do it as a reporter just
look at the transcript yeah and you can
like embed a little thing you know like
into your article right here's what they
said you can go listen to like this clip
from the section i'm actually trying to
trying to figure out i'll probably on
the website
create like a place where the transcript
goes like as a web page so that people
can
reference it like reporters can
reference and so on
i mean most of the reporters probably
have uh want to write click bait
articles that are complete falsifying
which i'm fine with it's the way of
journalism i don't
care like i've had this conversation
with
a friend of mine a mixed martial artist
the ryan hall
and we we talked about you know as i've
been reading the rise and fall the third
reich and a bunch of
books on hitler and we brought up hitler
and he
made some kind of comment where like
we should be able to forgive hitler
and uh you know like we were talking
about forgiveness and we're bringing
that up as like the worst case
possible thing is like even you know for
people
who are holocaust survivors one of the
ways to let go of the suffering they've
been through is
to is to forgive and he brought up like
hitler is somebody that would
would potentially be the the hardest
thing to possibly forgive but
it might be a worthwhile pursuit
psychologically and so on blah blah blah
it doesn't matter it was very eloquent
very powerful words i think
people should go back and listen to it
it's powerful and then
all these journalists there's all these
articles written about like
mma fight ufc fight all right love
hitler
no like well no they didn't they were
somewhat accurate
they didn't say like loves hitler they
said um
thinks that uh if hitler came back to
life
we should forgive him like they kind of
it's kind of
accurate-ish but it
it the headline makes it sound a lot
worse than
than uh than it was but i'm fine with it
that's the way
that's the way the world i wanna i wanna
almost make it easier for those
journalists
and make it easier for people who
actually care about the conversation to
go and look and see right they can see
it for themselves for themselves
there's something about podcasts like
the audio that makes it difficult to
to go to jump to a spot and to look
for that for that particular information
i think some of it you know i'm
interested in creating
like myself experimenting with stuff so
like they
taking rev and creating a transcript and
then people can go to it
i do dream that like i'm not in the loop
anymore
that like you know spotify does it
right like uh automatically for
everybody
because ultimately that one-click
purchase
needs to be there like like it kind of
wants support from the entire ecosystem
from the tool makers and the podcast
creators
even clients right i mean imagine if
like
uh most podcast apps you know
if it was a standard right here's how
you include a transcript into a podcast
right
like it's just an rss feed ultimately
and actually
uh just yesterday i saw this company
called bus sprout i think they're
called uh so so they're trying to do
this they
uh propose to spec um an extension to
their
rss format to reference podcast uh
reference transcripts in a standard way
yeah and they're talking about like
there's one
uh client dimension that will support it
but imagine like more clients support it
right so any podcast you could go um
and see the transcripts right in your
like normal podcast app yeah i mean
somebody so i have somebody who works
with me
uh his works helps with advertis with
advertising
uh matt this awesome guy he mentioned
bus brought to me but he says
it's really annoying because they want
exclusive uh they want to host the
podcast right this is the problem with
spotify too
uh this is where i'd like to say like
f spotify there's a magic to rss
with podcasts this it can be made
available to everyone
and then there's all there's this
ecosystem of different
podcast players that emerge and they
compete freely
and that that's a that's a beautiful
thing that that's why going exclusive
like joe rogan one exclusive
um i'm not sure if you're familiar with
he went just just spotify
as a huge fan of joe rogan i've been
kind of nervous about the whole thing
but
let's see let's i hope the spotify steps
up they've added video which was very
surprising that they were
so exclusive meaning you can't subscribe
to the rss feed anymore
only in spotify for now you can until
december 1st and december 1st
it all everything disappears and it's
spotify only
i uh you know and spotify gave him 100
million dollars for that
so it's it's uh it's an interesting deal
but
i i you know i did some soul searching
and
i'm glad he's doing it but if spotify
came to me with a hundred million
dollars
i wouldn't do it i wouldn't do well i
have a very different relationship with
money i hate money but
i just think i believe in the pirate
radio aspect of podcasting the fact
that and that there's something about
the source spirit the open source spirit
it just doesn't seem right it doesn't
feel right
that said you know because so many
people care about joe rogan's program
they're gonna hold spotify's feet to the
fire like
one of the cool things what joe told me
is the reason
he likes working with spotify is
that they
they're like ride or die together right
so they they want him to succeed
so that's why they're not actually
telling him what to do despite what
people think they they don't tell they
don't give them any notes on anything
they
want him to succeed and that's the cool
thing about exclusivity with the
platform
is like you kind of want each other to
succeed
and that process can actually be very
fruitful like youtube
it goes back to my criticism youtube
generally no matter how big the creator
may be for pewdiepie something like that
they want you to succeed
but for the most part from all the big
creators i've spoken with
veritasium all those folks you know they
get some basic assistance but it's not
like youtube doesn't care if you succeed
or not they have so many
yeah there's like 100 other data they
don't care so
and especially with um with somebody
like joe rogan
who youtube sees joe rogan not as a
person who might revolutionize the
nature of news
and idea space and nuanced conversations
they see him as a potential person who
uh
who has racist guests on or like
you know they see him as like a headache
potentially
so you know a lot of people talk talk
about this
it's a hard place to be for youtube
actually is
figuring out with the search and
discovery process
of how do you filter out conspiracy
theories and which conspiracy theories
represent
dangerous untruths and which conspiracy
theories
are like vanilla untruths and then
even when you have start having meetings
and discussions about what is true or
not
it starts getting weird yeah it's still
getting difficult these days right
i worry more about the other side right
of too much you know
too much censorship well maybe
censorship was the right word i mean
uh censorship is usually government
censorship but still uh
yeah putting yourself in the position of
arbiter for these kinds of things it's
very difficult and people think it's so
easy right like it's like well
you know like no nazis right what a
simple principle uh
but you know yes i mean no one likes
nazis yeah but
there's like many shades of grey yeah
like very soon after that
yeah and then you know of course
everybody you know there's some people
that call
our current president a nazi and then
there's like so you start getting uh
sam harris i don't know if you know that
is wasted
i in my opinion his conversation with
jack dorsey and i lost i spoke with jack
before in this podcast and we'll talk
again
but sam brought up uh sam harris does
not like donald trump
i i i do listen to his podcast i'm
familiar with his views on the matter
and he uh he has jack dorsey's like how
can you not ban
donald trump from twitter and so you
know there's a set
you have that conversation you have a
conversation where
some number some significant number of
people
think that the current president of the
united states should not be on your
platform
and it's like okay so if that's even on
the table as a conversation
then everything's on the table for
conversation
and yeah it's it's tough i'm not sure
where i
land on it i i'm with you i think that
censorship is bad but
i also think ultimately i just also
think you know
if you're the kind of person that's
going to be convinced you know
by some youtube video you know that
i don't know our government's been taken
over by aliens it's unlikely that like
you know you'll be returned to sanity
simply because you know that video is
not available on
on youtube right yeah i'm with you i
tend to believe in the intelligence of
people and we should
we should trust them but i also do think
it's the responsibility of platforms
to encourage more love in the world more
kindness to each other
and i don't always think that they're
great at doing that particular thing
so that that um
there's a nice balance there and i think
philosophically i think about that a lot
where's the balance between free speech
and like encouraging people even though
they have the freedom
of speech to not be an [ __ ] yeah
right that's not a constitutional like
uh so you have the right for to
first free speech but like just don't be
an [ __ ] like you can't really put
that in the constitution that the
supreme
court can't be like just don't be a dick
but
i feel like platforms have a role to be
like
just be nicer maybe do the carrot like
encourage people to be nicer
as opposed to the stake of censorship
but
i think it's it's an interesting machine
learning
problem just be nicer machine yeah
machine learning for niceness
it is i mean responsible ai i mean it is
it is a thing
um for sure jack dorsey kind of talks
about it
as a vision for twitter is how do we
increase the health of conversations
i don't know how seriously they're
actually trying to do that though
which is one of the reasons i am in part
considering
uh entering that space a little bit it's
difficult for them right because
you know it's kind of like well known
that you know people are
kind of driven by you know rage and you
know
uh outrage maybe is a better word right
outrage
drives engagement and well these
companies are
judged by engagement right so in the
short term but this goes to the metrics
thing that we were talking about earlier
i do believe
i have a fundamental belief that if you
have a metric of long-term happiness of
your users
like not short-term engagement but
long-term happiness and growth and
both like intellectual emotional health
of your users
you're going to make a lot more money
you're going to have long-term like
you should be able to optimize for that
you don't need to necessarily optimize
for engagement
yeah and that'll be good for society too
yeah no i mean i
i generally agree with you but it
requires a patient person with you know
trust from wall street to to be able to
carry out such a strategy this is the
was what i believe the steve jobs
character and elon musk's character is
like
you basically have to be so good at your
job
right you got to pass for anything that
you can hold the board
and every all the investors hostage by
saying like
either we do it my way or i leave
and everyone is too afraid of you to
leave right because they believe in your
vision
so that but that requires being really
good at uh really good at what you do
requires being steve jobs and elon musk
there's kind of a reason why like a
third name doesn't come immediately to
mine right like there is maybe a handful
of other people but
it's not that many it's not many i mean
people say like why like
people say that i'm like a fan of elon
musk i'm not i'm a fan of anybody
who's like steve jobs and elon musk and
there's
not many of those folks it's a guy that
made us believe that like we can get to
mars
you know in 10 years right i mean that's
kind of awesome
and it's kind of making it happen which
is like
it's it's great like that kind of like
spirit right like from a lot of our
society right you know
like we can get to the moon in 10 years
and like we did it right yeah
especially in this time of uh so much
kind of existential dread that people
are going through because of
covid right like having rockets that
just keep
going out there now with humans i don't
know
that uh it just like you said i mean it
gives you a reason to wake up in the
morning and and dream
of forest engineers too
it is inspiring as hell man
you